melissa
is in new york city hi melissa welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris i think you guys are
awesome for the record
and i appreciate you guys in my life um
i'm just a little stressed right now i
need a little guidance
i'm on baby step 3d um i have two
children
uh one on the way i'm in the position to
buy um
i have a dump i have my down payment and
i have um 2.75 interest rate i was told
for for seniors
um but i i didn't want to continue
renting because there's some issues with
my apartment
right now and they want me to come out
because they have to like fix some leak
and they have to like
open up the walls anyways on the issue
is that i want to be
an hour commute to the city because i
live in new york city
um but of course you know how city
prices are
um and that's without without traffic
i'm just looking at an hour commute
without traffic
so i thought i found the property and i
was just wondering it's not anything
that i wanted
in real life um but it's gonna be my
first property it's a condo i really
wanted a single family home
but the condo is more within my budget
um and it would be less than if i were
to be renting
um there's no backyard i could um
so i was just wondering if i should just
settle for a condo
um or if i should rent continue renting
and try to save up for another property
or
could i keep the condo and then maybe
sell it in three years
but then i'm not really sure how it
works in the market and if i if it would
be easy to sell in the future okay stop
um what happened is you have to move
earlier than your plan and
you don't quite have the down payment
you initially dreamed of having when you
made this move
uh and it's stressing you out
[Music]
you're getting ready to accept some
piece of crap condo that you don't want
i know why because you're stressed out
well because i'm in a good position i
mean i feel like i'm in a good position
today because i have my
security why would you buy something
that's crappy
it looks nice you haven't looked enough
i've been looking since january i've
been looking a lot
this is really aggressive in the market
right now
um and things are on the market for a
short period of time
and then they just go um because i've
been looking
in the in the new jersey area close to
the city
[Music]
and it seems to be like i don't know i
can't find
anything that's an hour away yeah what
you described to me
was you said i don't like this condo
should i buy it anyway
that's what you said is that what she
said yes because you're tired
you're tired of looking melissa you did
say that you said it real clearly
because it's like it's like an apartment
so i could
i could just get it because it's like an
apartment so i if i rent an apartment it
would be 2500
and then if i buy the condo it would be
like 2 000.
you said i don't like this condo should
i buy it anyway
okay that's what you said because of the
rent's too high
because i don't want to move twice
because i've been looking and i haven't
found anything
and i'm frustrated should i buy this
condo that i don't like should i
surrender and buy a condo that i don't
like
that's what you've been saying the whole
time you've been on the phone
you're gonna get in there and within
five or six months you're gonna be
miserable
yeah so you need to either go rent
something and calm down
and look more slowly or you need to take
more time and find something different
but you told us over and over
in this call just go back and listen to
this when it's on the podcast
it was melissa saying i hate this condo
should i buy it anyway
you said it five different ways you use
different languages yeah or different
words
because it would be my own no no
no it would be your own and you hate it
have you not ever owned something you
hated
i have deep inside your spirit is saying
i hate this condo don't buy it maybe
dave will tell me i should anyway
and he's not going to he's not going to
tell you that
i've owned crap that i hated and i hated
it the whole time i hated it and i gave
it away when i got ready to sell it
because i hated it
okay so either go rent a little while
longer even though it's wasted money
but it's better than buying something
you hate am i missing something no
not at all or even if it takes you
longer to commute in
find something you like that would
that's inside of your budget
i promise you you will not regret that
it's tiny it doesn't have a backyard
i don't like it i don't like it i don't
like it i don't like it but i've been
looking forever
and i got to move because they're
tearing the walls out of my condo i'm
frustrated
should i buy it anyway no no
don't do that to yourself
[Laughter]
you answered your own question here's
another way of saying it melissa
a friend of mine says that god's spirit
is inside of you and he says
it's talking to you and it says when in
doubt
on a decision when in doubt don't
if you don't have peace there's a
disturbance
when in doubt don't
and every time that little bell inside
of me rings
and i go forward anyway
i pay stupid tax and i have god help me
paid so much stupid tax
in my life you know i was thinking about
this morning
the first house i ever bought chris
i was working for a real estate company
a builder
and a national builder and they took
this little house and antioch tennessee
in on trade
against one of the houses that we had
sold in the subdivision
and they said hey we can't get rid of it
let's see if dave will buy it
this house was uglier than ugly
one of those tennessee houses where they
cut the road through the middle of the
street and the houses below
you can stand on the front porch and see
the oil pan cars going by
and the houses above are a ski slope and
ugly it was perched up on a hill
a gully you ugly with a capital u ugly
but i got a deal because they sold it to
me nothing down they carried back the
second mortgage and i assumed the fha
first mortgage
i was thinking about when i was running
this morning i had i paid 59
250 for that house you know how i
remember that
was that because i sold it four years
later for
two hundred 59 fifty dollars and felt
blessed to be
out of the ugly house just let it go
home ownership was not all it was cut
out to be when it's carved out of this
out of a freaking cloud
cliff and it's ugly i hated that house
when i bought it
i hated that house when i sold it
melissa this is how i know your story
i've lived your story darling
dave's trying to save you listen listen
i've done so many stupid things in my
life that was my first home purchase
by god as a homeowner you got a deal
stupid and ugly
but i was a homeowner